I've had women in their 40s break down
in tears crying basically saying I'm
alone my eggs are frozen I don't have a
man I used to be hot now guys don't look
at me the same I was fed a crock of
by feminism okay but taking it a step
further I also interview a ton of model
volleyball that I was just at I was just
we did rolling loud we did Ultra we just
did Tortuga interview a ton of women who
are all in their early 20s in their
mid-20s and they're going down this path
I don't need no man I don't like all
that and to see the writing on the wall
of what the future will hold I think is
what I'm most concerned about nobody
gives a about what Chelsea does
with her life it's the fact that her
eight million followers or whoever's
going to her show are gonna be fed this
bull crap and I when I see women cry
break down wish that they had a better
life than what they have now I think
that's the biggest problem